et si j'ai symbole éclatant de la
supériorité des mines possédait en effet
une municipalité en jupons ou les
conseillers étaient des conseillères et
où le maire madame et locke renier
puissance incontestée 1947
le fait est tellement rare que les
actualités françaises y consacrent sujet
une femme à la tête d'une commune à
l'époque les femmes représentent moins
d'un pour cent des mères 24 ans plus
tard en 1971
la situation n'a pas tellement évolué
sur y est d'accord pour qu'une femme
devienne maire de grimaud
pourquoi pas mais on manque à l'état si
intelligente les pros de raison
moi non la femme a que ses occupations
ménages vous n'êtes pas de printemps des
associations comme l'union féminine
civique et sociale organise des stages
pour inciter les femmes à se présenter
aux municipales
je crois que les femmes ont beaucoup de
courage pour lutter contre contre le pin
occupé mais dans les urnes seulement 1,8
pour cent de femmes sont élues maires en
1971 les scrutins se succèdent et la
part des femmes mère augmente doucement
lentement pour arriver à 7,5 pour cent
de femmes élues aux élections
municipales de 1995
mais pour les élections de 2001 une loi
tente de bousculer la donne et les
femmes me direz-vous dans tout ça et
bien 2001 sera leur année avec la loi
sur la parité
elles vont en effet arrivés en masse sur
la scène politique les partis doivent
désormais vous le savez présenter un
nombre égal d'hommes et de femmes les
communes de plus de 3500 habitants sont
donc désormais obligés de présenter
autant d'hommes que de femmes
mais à l'arrivée les femmes se
retrouvent relégués loin très loin dans
les listes la parité certes mais à pas
mesurés dans la très grande majorité de
ces villes
les hommes restent aux commandes des
mairies
si le nombre de conseillère municipale
augmente le nombre de femmes à la tête
d'une commune passe tout juste la barre
des 10 % en 2001 en 2014 même si la loi
pour la parité s'étend aux villes de
plus de 1000 habitants
le nombre de femmes à la tête d'une
commune est resté en dessous des 20%
[Musique]